grab some scissors in a Clark Bar it's
the only Clark
Bar because we're about to meet the
biggest nurse you've ever seen you yell
or make noise I'll tear your trachy out
and your last thought would be holy
he really did it that's right folks we
have only one more episode until the
season 2 finale of Reacher which means
another video where the people who've
read the books laugh at how wrong my
theories are the season is really
ramping up to an epic finale and in this
video we'll be answering whether or not
Rosco will return how Senator Lavoy may
play into all this and just where on
Earth is Tony Swan so be sure to like
And subscribe so that next week you're
notified as soon as my finale video
drops but in the meantime let's check
out episode 7 with the death of
detective Gano Russo Reacher and the
team are on the defensive Langston will
stop at nothing to take out Reacher and
his team and Reacher knows this is not a
place for a young girl like Jane who was
almost killed last episode so Jane and
Marlo will need a safe place to hide
until Langston can be stopped for good
but everyone Reacher knows is already
involved in this case that is everyone
but Rosco the Romantic lead from season
1 and as soon as Dixon hears another
woman's name she's like who's Rosco
Reacher ends up sending Marlo and Jane
to a friend of Dixon's in Buffalo
Circuit City overrun by wild
dogs just until things cool off it won't
be forever we just need to kill a few
more people upate New York
but does the mere mention of Rosco mean
she could show up in the finale we did
see Finley return for a brief Cameo and
if she were to make an appearance what
better way than in the finale but I'm
going to put this at about a 10% chance
so while odonnell and Dixon make sure
Marlo and Jane get off on their way
Reacher is going to pay a visit to
Lieutenant Marsh Russo's boss who's been
secretly working with Langston last
episode we learned Marsh was taking
bribes from him in exchange for info on
Reacher and his team and it seems as
though Marsh knows Reacher will be after
him considering he's caught packing a
duffel bag full of cash and a gun now
there's nothing that pisses Reacher off
more than someone who messes with one of
his friends let alone someone who's also
a dirty cop so he gives him a deal turn
himself in and tell him where this deal
is happening between LST and am or die
but Marsh claims he has no idea where
this deal is taking place but he knows
someone who does remember that guy who
got ran over last
episode that's got to hurt I don't care
where you're from well it turns out he's
still alive and in hospital but before
Reacher can head on over Marshall lunges
for his gun and you can imagine what
happens everyone dies eventually Reacher
grabs a stack of bills and finally pays
Neely back for all those clothes plane
tickets and accommodation he's been
using throughout the season something
that was set up all the way back in
episode 4 I'll pay you back in two
months meanwhile Dixon watches as
odonnell works his dad magic easing
Jane's anxiety this is a guy who said
he'd never settled down but now has his
own family I am unattached for life if
you've been watching my previous videos
I've long suspected odonnell and to a
lesser extent Dixon as a secret villain
but with the two of them getting the
kicked out of them and a knife
stabed in Dixon's shoulder this is
seeming less and less likely but cut me
a little slack odonnell was first
discovered in Reacher trashed hotel room
he constantly accuses Tony Swan as being
a bad guy has a burner phone that his
kids somehow call and was suspiciously
not around when that bomb was being set
up at the end of episode 5 maybe he's
just a really good red herring this
episode also sees the conclusion to
operation kitr Runner the Siu's
investigation into military personnel
using military planes to smuggle heroin
out of Afghanistan in episode 6
Reacher's commanding officer tells him
to stop the investigation due to the bad
look it would give the new Colonel it
makes me question whether fields in this
Colonel may have been involved as well
regardless Reacher goes ahead with
taking down this operation when they
hear a big deal is going down tonight
two years of their hard work has led to
this moment and thus Reacher asks his
team if they are willing to defy their
orders and follow him to do what is
right to which all of them agree the
search proves to be fruitful with
hundreds of pounds of heroin stashed
within the spare tires of these trucks
and something I found very interesting
is that Reacher is correct in most cases
a warrant is not required in a military
investigation there just needs to be
probable cause and there doesn't even
need to be anything written down on
paper but the bust goes sideways when
the buyers arrive and cause a massive
shootout culminating in one of the
criminals facing Reacher Swift Justice
you broke my leg I broke the fence fall
broke your leg which is similar to what
he said to the guy in the heart attack
in episode 3 he was stopped by barbecue
he died from trans fats as you can
imagine Fields is none too pleased at
Reacher's exploits it's ultimately
relieving everyone of their Duty
effective immediately leaving Reacher to
his fallback job a nurse yes if this guy
came in as my nurse ready to give me a
colonoscopy I for sure wouldn't make it
after threatening to burst their
suspects urethra with a catheter Reacher
uncovers that this big trade-off between
Langston and am is happening sometime
tomorrow at 5:00 a.m. and when Reacher
is done with this guy he fills his
intravenus up which is definitely not
good bedside manner while leaving the
hospital Reacher Neely find one of
Langston's goons who is also
conveniently dressed up like a nurse I
would not want to be a patient here this
confrontation ends with a one-on-one
fight between neie and this dude until
Reacher comes in and Saves the
Day
I wanted to question him luckily
this guy still has his phone on him
which Reacher uses to contact Langston
and I think this is like the third time
in the season Reacher has killed one of
Langston's guys and uses their phone to
call them is it done not in the way you
expected before you ask if it's done it
is is give me some good news sure you're
down another man but I left his body in
the morg for convenience Langston wants
Reacher to meet him at new ages research
and development Warehouse where he will
remain underwat until his deal with am
is finished promising Reacher that he
can then be released unharmed sure Jan
Langston's captured Dixon and O'Donnell
as added incentive now this is where a
lot of setup for next episode comes into
play first Reacher tells Langston that
Neely was killed allowing Neely to keep
guard on the Warehouse when he
eventually goes in then there's the
question of Senator Lavoy who in episode
5 came to Reacher to strike a deal in
exchange for his resources Reacher would
keep the Senator's involvement in this
missile business Hush Hush these
resources include two Navy Seals and a
ranger who we haven't yet seen then
there's this quick shot of Reacher
taking out a brass Fastener from The New
Age employee list I wonder if this will
help him get out of handcuffs or some
sort of confinement let's not forget
that the fence surrounding the warehouse
is electrified they wouldn't have gone
through this whole rigar roll of a kid
throwing a beer can at it if this fence
doesn't come into play somehow next
episode eat N I like that kid we
also see am inspect the missiles from
the same guy who stole the transport
truck in episode 5 remember that am has
to do this deal in person because he
holds on to these untraceable barabond
and am doesn't trust anyone but himself
to hold on to them with am in possession
of the money and the missile
all he needs right now is Langston's
engineer to insert the microchips when
this is done am will be in possession of
650 surfac to- a missiles that could
wreak unfathomable Havoc across the
globe keep in mind we haven't learned
am's real goal here but I suspect with
him being an arms dealer he plans on
reselling these missiles to terrorist
groups across the world I was also
caught off guard by this final
conversation between Reacher and neie in
which Reacher is extremely pessimistic
about life people live and then they die
die everyone dies eventually this all
went to you wouldn't be the last
member of the 110th for long they'd kill
you within 24 hours it isn't necessarily
the most rousing speech you want to hear
before embarking On A Dangerous Mission
with Neely watching from afar Reacher
makes his way inside the compound with
Dixon and odonnal tied to gurny it
definitely doesn't look good for Reacher
but keep in mind he's supposed to have
these backup Navy Seals and Rangers
somewhere out there then there's the
question of Tony Swan where is this guy
Marlo told us that Swan was was on her
side while the guy who opened fire at
Fran's funeral said that it was Swan who
hired him to undertake this shooting
Swan definitely has a lot of explaining
to do so I wouldn't be surprised if
we'll see him next episode according to
IMDb the last episode is titled Fly Boy
so I wonder if we'll see someone flying
out of a helicopter remember that
Reacher did promise to kill Langston by
throwing him out of one I want to throw
you out of a helicopter but now I turn
it over to you what do you think will
happen in the finale I want to hear your
thoughts and theories in the comments
below thanks for watching make sure to
like And subscribe and for more bad
takes you can follow me on Twitter and
Instagram at thinkstory YT until next
time remember he was stopped by barbecue
he died from trans
fats